I've been an atsc driver a stormtrooper
I've been an indoor rebel sometimes we
are able to actually put our faces on to
star wars characters back in the day had
a little less gray I am a toy designer I
love toys it's more than just a job I'm
probably best known for working on Star
Wars I first started back in nineteen
seventy seven and that's right when we
received the Star Wars license you have
this film that everybody kind of passed
on we say kind of like oh for fifty
dollars in a handshake we got the Star
Wars license I kind of gravitated
towards the vehicle I think I had the
temperament and the patience to do the
vehicle development my first big major
project was a Malayan Falcon and I'm
designing the new vehicles for episode 7
we had to be able to design the turrets
so that it would hold Chewbacca but and
then also standard sort of six foot
characters well we've got a base agree
to the script because we haven't seen
the film yet and we don't know all of
the little quirks that happen with the
Falcon we kind of went for a lot of what
we call off camera features they don't
really exist in the film for instance
that turret popping up does not actually
exist even though it's made up it wants
to be like oh wow yeah that was a
feature it's really in the Millennium
Falcon they just never happened to press
it but Star Wars is you know just kind
of in-your-face gritty there's hinges
there's piping there's electrical
there's events all that stuff that make
it real
even though it's a galaxy far far away I
think Star Wars is real the other fancy
space ships but there's that certain
sort of love for going on adventures
toys embody all of the fantasy that kids
love to engage in they come out of the
film all I just love this film the toys
then allow the kids to bring that
fantasy to life every day
you